we really don't know how this new
information is going to affect their
lives
we discovered it like right before we
shot it they grew up you know 16 years
believing that they were
i can say it right
[Applause]
what do you think he's doing here oh
you're lucky i didn't use my gun that's
okay
we'll use ours well ladies i loved
teenage bounty hunter so much it's so
unique
it's action-packed it's funny you two
play fraternal twins on the show
and you have such a fun connection
how did you guys bond off screen to
really bring that sisterly connection on
screen
it was really the most magical thing
ever as soon as we met we just became
obsessed with each other
like literally at the chemistry read
when we first met i was like don't want
to go for dinner like you want to go
like wanna go
and we were literally just like talking
like this like the whole time he's been
like oh like let's manifest
envision and in this like really crowded
restaurant we were just like staring at
each other and like talking and like
laughing when like
i remember maddie grabbed her diet coke
and she like missed her mouth with the
straw and we like laughed for like 15
minutes like she was like
um but i think like off screen i think
what was so great about doing the show
together was like we would just like
share ear paws
when we were you know preparing for a
scene and i think we kind of did
have this and do have this like
simpatico of like understanding each
other without really having to say a lot
of words
yeah it's a really cool like yang that
we've got
we're very similar in some ways but
we're different enough that like i can
give angelica advice about things and
she can give me advice about things so
it's just like a really
easy wicked relationship this has to
remain top secret
you're right twins
let's talk about the finale so we're
gonna i know
way to leave us i'm quite the
cliffhanger
what do you want to say to fans after
they've finished binging that first
season because you know that netflix
fans their immediate reaction is going
to be
what's next so what do you guys know
about season two oh they don't tell us
anything
we didn't know what was gonna happen in
the next episode like when we would film
they really kept it under wraps which
i think made it easier and more fun for
us because we kind of just like
discovered things along the way
but i think what's really specifically
cool about episode 10 though if i may
because i
what what i would want to say to viewers
is like you are right in tandem with the
girls
as far as understanding i'm getting
emotional as far as understanding like
what their future is gonna be
yeah together and what it means for
their relationship
i think that it's a really interesting
place
coming from the two girls to say we
really don't know how
this new information is gonna affect
their lives and
they grew up you know 16 years believing
that they were
i can say it right believing that they
were twins and
it's definitely going to be a journey
and
the audience has this like rare you know
opportunity to be right and stuff with
us
and see when if and when the show does
continue how it will affect
the girls emotionally yeah i think it
would be such a beautiful thing the way
that the audience is just going along
with the girls like they don't know any
more than the girls do
and um i just think it's such a special
like intimate thing
they're good good job well we will see
y'all at home
did they tell you the i'm gonna call it
the twin twist did they tell you that
ahead of time or did you discover it in
the script
and what was your reaction we discovered
it like
right before we got it it was i remember
literally texting angelica and being
like
sup cuz you're like are you my cousin
kathleen is a sick woman
a sick woman
yeah it was emotional it was so
emotional i think that
when you think of it in regards to twin
vision the fact that they still have
twin vision
it's like it's not a scientific like
biological thing it's because they're so
connected and they love each other and
like
they grew up believing they were twins
so of course they still have that
connection
and i think this show is like a real
testament to like sisterhood
and yeah that and how and how women can
have sisterhood even when
they're not actually related
as they were discovering all these
secrets about their family
about their mom that it really put a
strain
on this family where do you think they
can go from here now that this
information is out there
i don't know i really i know
it i really don't know it's such an
insane
um twist that like i couldn't have
fathomed it
that i can't i'm just like i have no
idea but that i feel like you'll have to
tune in to find out like
you know i really it really is such a
perfect binging show like i'm excited
for people to experience this like
roller coaster ride
totally totally my friend's class of
it's like a procedural kind of
show and i'm like no there's like really
a through line
story that you kind of like you really
want you don't want to miss a beat
we are really nailing this work-life
balance why do women complain so much
it's super easy to have it all
[Music]